now you guys know Russell Brand
right now Russell Brand just made a
video called why he wears the cross and
he says I'm interested to hear what you
think okay Russell so let's go ahead and
watch your video and I'm going to let
you know what I think the reason I wear
a cross is because Christianity and in
particular the figure of Christ uh it
seems to me inevitably becoming more
important as I become more familiar with
suffering purpose self and not self it
occurred to me that if instead of always
talking to myself inwardly I could
replace one of those voices with an
indwelling God I'm very interested to
hear what you think because for me My
Heart is Open let me know think why do
you wear this cross and we ask this
question with
humility sincerity and love truly
wanting the best for all of mankind not
with any hate or trying to put somebody
down we are just sincerely trying to get
people to intellectually think why if
Jesus who we love dearly by the way is
one of the mightiest Messengers ever
sent by God who was calling the people
to only worship the one Almighty Creator
not himself or his Blessed Mother Mary
but only the Creator alone without any
intermediaries now back to the question
why do you wear the cross around your
neck have you really thought about it or
are you just blindly imitating and
fitting
in someone might say this represents his
sacrifice and his dying for my sins on
the cross side note Jesus never ever
told people to worship him as a god
literal Son of God or that he was coming
to die for people's sins this has
nothing to do with his true message or
teachings which we'll get to in a moment
if Jesus as you say was killed just for
an example on an electric chair would
you be wearing a miniature
representation of an electric chair
around your neck or if he was
hung would it be a rope killed with a
machete or if they had guns at that time
and was killed in front of a firing
squad would you be wearing a 30 caliber
Winchester rifle or bow and arrow around
your neck
you see the cross has become a good luck
charm an idol in and of itself which
totally goes against Jesus's true
teachings and message so by wearing the
cross and worshiping him you are totally
doing opposite of what he told you to do
we see rappers gangsters fashion
celebrities wearing this modern-day Idol
around their necks while doing the most
evil things the cross at the end of the
day can't help you only the almighty can
help you if you turn to him alone there
are some very sincere and good people
whom really love Jesus and is those
people whom we want to help educate and
let them know that this is exactly what
Jesus and all the messengers whom the
Creator sent warned people
against and that was against idol
worship or anything that can lead up to
it against human worship Saint worship
and any kind of creation worship they
all called people to worship the Creator
alone and not his creation at your worst
of times and the best of times to only
call on the almighty alone without any
middlemen to stay away from Black Magic
Spirit Worship supposed good luck charms
and these strange and weird incantations
and
superstitions to think and to not
blindly follow your
ancestors and popular cultural
Traditions if you really love Jesus do
what he told you to do he only worshiped
the Creator and called people away from
creation worship there is a statement
that we can confirm he said because it
matches the consistent message of all
the prophets and The Messengers that the
almighty sent it's in John 17:3 it says
now this is eternal life that they may
know you referring to the almighty
Creator to the one God the only true God
and Jesus Christ whom you have sent that
is Islam the shahada this is the truth
submitting to the fact that there is
nothing worthy of any kind of worship
except the one Creator alone and Prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon Him
is the last and final messenger that
would automatically include the belief
in all the messengers that came before
him including Abraham Moses and Jesus
the Messiah the Christ this is pure
monotheism I tell people that a great
place to start is in the heart you got
to be sincere and earnestly asking the
almighty alone to guide you to that
which is pleasing to him start doing
that today well there you go Russell
this is what I think about the whole
situation you got my sincere advice with
respect and love give that some thought
and I'd like to hear what you guys think
go ahead and leave that in the comments
below and one more thing before you go
if you'd like a free copy of the Quran
go go to theed Deen show.com I'll get
you one for free and if you lik that
video you can watch this one here and
you can watch this one here hit that
notification Bell subscribe if you
haven't already until next time peace be
with you assalam
alaykum alhamdulillah brothers and
sisters we've acquired the future Dean
Center property and we want to get the
mhid open first it's all coming along
we're installing the doors we can make
woo we've installed the carpets we have
many details to finish up but it's
coming along alhamdulillah we need a new
roof we need new windows and we need a
minbar that's right we need a minbar for
the mid now if all of you want to be a
part of history and help build a house
of worship build a Masjid for the sake
of Allah so Allah the Creator can build
for you a house in Jenna click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
you